there are now 12 Democrats running for
president 12 does that's a dozen well a
dozen yeah isn't that crazy only 12
people in this country think they can do
a better job than Donald Trump only 12
out of 300 million people everyone else
is like I can't compete with that
the latest here's the latest of the 12
people the latest candidate is the
former governor of Colorado and his name
is John Hickenlooper John Hickenlooper
that is where I draw the line I'm sorry
I know he might be very qualified I know
nothing about him we cannot have a
president Hickenlooper I'm not we are a
country not a dr. Seuss book I I don't
want to know anything more about it you
know he's already got a big celebrity
endorsement
Benedict Cumberbatch it's come a batch
for Hickenlooper
who's his running mate gonna be probably
Charlie stepping spittle I just made
that name up but I just I don't even
know how are you gonna get that on a
bumper sticker now it's very cumbersome
stipple right right no I know I'm not
I'm not in today I think Andy you might
run next right I don't know is anyone
here this guy should run the guy I mean
with the beard the rule guy me with
testosterone I love it
I've always wanted to see what it would
look like and there it is